most endings in hollywood movies follow
the specific cliche of the happy ending
the problems of the plot are resolved
and the future looks bright
but why are unfortunate endings still so
satisfying
let's take a look at how hollywood has
trained us to watch films and how
anti-happy endings satisfy
and stick with us by portraying reality
over fantasy
that my friends is the ugly truth
hollywood films have been formatted
since the 1970s in a very specific
formula that is meant to sell the most
films and appeal to mass audiences
this aim for mass appeal has determined
most films to follow a similar plot
structure which is always capped off
with a happy ending
these happy endings are meant to bring
the viewers a sense of completeness
and satisfaction anti-happy movie
endings play off of the expectations
viewers already have to the movie
endings
they know that the viewer wants to see
the plot resolved and the protagonist
thriving
so they take these elements away leaving
the audience hanging
in suspense and stuck on a cliffhanger
what makes a good happy ending
is it the character's ability to finally
find love is it the magical and perfect
resolution of all of their problems
present in the rest of the film
regardless of your personal definition
of a happy ending hollywood would say a
happy ending embodies all of these
things
happy endings as we know them wrap the
entirety of the narrative present in the
film
up into a singular plot point once we
think about it a bit more
the idea of a happy ending is quite
impressive it takes all of the
complexity of a film and resolves it
with one foul swoop
at least this is how happy endings may
appear in reality the hollywood happy
ending doesn't really need to perfectly
wrap up everything in the narrative
it only needs to wrap up enough of it
that the viewers don't notice some
things that are missing or unsolved
the happiness that these endings put
forth relies on the idea of completeness
as in the narrative itself comes full
circle and is complete
so the protagonist must have met their
goals for example
interstellar concludes with the savior
of humankind through murphy's work
this leaves the audience appeased with
the resolution of much of the plot
strife
however it is unexplained why the
tesseract collapses
sending cooper back into our solar
system considering it was an unnecessary
and
almost impossible step in the narrative
his arrival back to the solar system
makes no practical sense
but is still a prominent plot point just
to further drive home the complete
happy ending where father reunites with
daughter
interstellar is just one example of this
type of expectation meeting ending
but nearly every film produced in
hollywood embodies this repetitive
happily ever after
this formulaic creation of conclusions
has worked to shape the way in which
audiences watch movies
hollywood sets us up with exact
expectations there will be a distinct
beginning
middle and conclusion of a narrative and
that conclusion will be a complete and
happy one
when we sit down to watch a movie and it
doesn't follow this structure
say a non-linear film like i'm thinking
of ending things
people oftentimes get bored or confused
and stop watching
this is what drives hollywood to keep
repeating the same plot format
first kiss the break-up
the makeup it keeps people watching
because it feeds into their expectations
and therefore makes the producers and
filmmakers money let's move on to what
distinguishes a specifically
unhappy ending in hollywood this would
include any ending that doesn't leave
viewers with a sense of completeness
one that seems to be lacking in some
regard typically eliciting feelings of
sadness
anger or loss from the viewers it is
both the content of the ending
what we see playing out on screen and
the structure of it the feeling that
something is missing
that combined to produce an emotional
sensation for the viewer
let's look through some films with
notoriously sad anti-happy endings and
see what kind of effect
this type of ending has on the viewer i
love movies like that
yeah it's great midsummer's ending was
not all sad
but was without a doubt a violent and
horrifying one very much unlike the
ending to a film like mamma mia parasite
also came to a crashing close with a
violent attack by goonse
ruining the park family party and mr kim
becoming the next victim of the cycle of
poverty tied with the park's home
in the joker the plot builds up to make
it seem like the joker might have some
sort of a happy conclusion
but with his dark twist at the end the
audience is left horrified and saddened
by his downfall
all of these horror suspense films use
the unhappy ending to communicate
realism to their audiences
this means that the anti-happy endings
used in these films work to make the
narrative closer to reality
think about it if all the terrible
things that happened in midsummer
parasite and the joker happened in real
life what are the odds of
everything turning out fine that's right
slim to none
anti-happy endings are not only used to
establish a sense of reality for the
filmic narrative
but also inherently break out
expectations and stick with us because
we don't see them coming
this can be seen best in dramas and
romance films that really
build up relationships and heartwarming
characters so that we expect them to
mold into the traditional happily ever
after ending that hollywood often
promises
but when this isn't delivered viewers
are shocked and a memorable effect is
granted to that film's ending
this aspect of anti-happy endings can be
seen in the films gone girl
la la land shutter island and the boy in
the stripe pajamas
after gone girl's plot being full of
twists and turns the ending leaves nick
and amy in a toxic marriage that seems
perfect to the public
rather than amy getting her true
deserved revenge la la land is one of
the most built up and bittersweet
endings in film
as mia and sebastian see each other
years after their relationship ended
having taken two separate heartbreaking
paths for their own careers
shutter island's ending is also
considered to be a huge twist
as teddy's mental state gets called into
question and suddenly the audience
realizes he is the crazy one of the
narrative
and lastly the boy in the striped
pajamas has to be considered the saddest
movie ending of all time
still coming as a twist in the
trajectory of the film as the audience
expected a reprieve from the melancholy
of the rest of the plot
in all of these films the sad or
anti-happy ending
always came as a surprise creating a
lasting memorable and satisfying
experience for the viewers
while simultaneously situating them
closer to reality
now that we understand what the
difference between happy and anti-happy
endings are
in terms of hollywood production it will
be interesting to reimagine the endings
of notorious anti-happy ending movies
and see whether or not this adjustment
would benefit or detriment the quality
of the film
we'll start off with midsummer had this
film ended with a happy cliche ending
i'm sure that dany would have chosen to
sacrifice a random villager
rather than christian she would have
then waited for the hallucinogen to wear
off and would calm down before talking
with christian
and deciding to leave back to the united
states together back home the two would
have bonded over the trauma they
experienced and gone to therapy which
would allow them to grow closer and move
on in their relationship
this ending would be so much less
satisfying than the actual ending of
midsummer as it necessitates dany
sticking with her careless boyfriend who
treated her poorly
that's not her again seriously
had parasite had a typical hollywood
ending then mr kim would not get trapped
under the house
as goonse was and would instead make it
out after the murderous birthday party
get a high-paying job and ultimately buy
back the home that caused him so much
trauma
as his son is trying aimlessly to do at
the end of the actual film
had this been mr kim's fate the idea of
the cycle of poverty and the
anti-capitalist messaging of the film
would have completely dissolved and
meant nothing in the end
if the joker were to end positively
joker would be attending a fully funded
rehabilitation center and would be
making great progress in his steps
towards reintegration into society
he would be granted outside visitors and
would be working through his emotional
burden of the lies that his mother told
him
she says i was put here to spread joy
and laughter he would forgive his mother
and
ultimately come out a better person
because of the emotional work she forced
him to do
this ending would be unsatisfying
because it ultimately fails to set up
the joker's character for the rest of
his fictional existence
and would have been a very confusing
backstory for someone who was considered
one of the most evil villains in the
media
gone girl had the potential to be a
truly different film had the ending
changed to be a classic hollywood
happily
ever after much like midsummer upon
amy's return home her husband nick would
beg for forgiveness and she would agree
to work on the relationship with him
the two would go to couples therapy and
amy would admit to faking her own death
to the media
participating in supplemental therapy to
get over the urges that made her do that
in the first place
the two would put their differences
aside and realize that marriage is the
most important thing of all
deciding to love each other regardless
of their flaws in the end
who would want an ending to gone girl as
flimsy as this
it would take all of the revenge out of
the revenge plot and would make amy out
to be submissive to the institution of
marriage
rather than an independent woman who was
capable of much more than her meek
husband
in another alternate ending amy would
not have returned back home at all
instead fleeing the country and having
nick locked up for her murder
amy would be lounging in the sun next to
a pool in mexico with a whole new look
as a disguise
while her husband goes through the
process of prison intake this ending is
not necessarily
the happy ending of hollywood's dreams
but could be considered as happy as
midsummer's ending currently
is to certain viewers nick doesn't
necessarily get what he wants or
deserves but we are ultimately rooting
for amy
having amy come out on top could be a
whole new level of anti-happy happy
ending
in la la land the happy platitude of an
ending that would have made the film
conform to viewers expectations
would have had mia and sebastian
ultimately end up together
rather than parting ways for the sake of
their dreams and careers
i haven't heard from you in a little
while their love would overpower their
individual desires and they would
sacrifice their passion for each other
this ending is clearly much weaker than
the actual ending of the film
as it requires the relinquishment of
individuality from both of the
protagonists for the sake of romance
this ending would have characterized mia
and sebastian as co-dependent and
unhealthy in their relationship
which might seem temporarily more happy
than the ending that exists
but in the long run would be detrimental
to their emotional well-being
plus who can forget this bittersweet
ending we sure didn't
i'm bruno i'm schmoll
as for the boy in the striped pajamas
bruno would have entered the
concentration camp and would have
rescued small
taking him back to the safety of his
house with bruno's parents open and
willing to care for him
shutter island would have taken on a
hollywood ending only if teddy was in
fact right in his paranoia and it turned
out that the entirety of the mental
institution was a site for government
testing
he would be deemed a national hero by
the army and would live in pride for the
rest of his days
teddy daniels the man the legend i'll
give you that the legend
but would it have had as big of an
impact on the audience
probably not the use of anti-happy
endings isn't just a trick up
filmmaker's sleeves to make people
unhappy or confused at the end of their
films instead
these more realistic endings allow
viewers to feel closer to the narrative
of the film itself
and doesn't leave its audience with the
glow of an immaculate conclusion
empathy becomes a much bigger tool for
filmmakers when using non-happy endings
than when they stick to the cliche
making these films more memorable and
honest in this way
anti-happy endings can actually make a
film more likeable and respectable
because they aren't obviously trying to
gimmick their viewers into a fantasy of
an end
this was very obviously seen in our
exercise of reimagining anti-happy
endings as the films always came out
worse with a happy ending rather than a
realistic one
the next time you watch a movie with an
anti-happy ending ask yourself
does this feel more real than a sappy
cliche outro
why was i expecting something different
because of my own values
or because of the norms of the film
industry